what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcast in crypto let's kick
this thing off Phil Chen is the general
partner at proof of capital and the
decentralized chief officer at the HTC
Exodus in this conversation we discuss
hardware wallets what they built with
the HTC Exodus why certain features were
included how big companies can drive
innovation and what Phil is excited
about moving forward in the
cryptocurrency industry I really enjoyed
this conversation and I hope you do as
well skirt school want to know who has
the best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm their crypto platform with
one goal mother in mass adoption that's
why we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet Curto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out tell them pump sent
you download the app or visit crypto
comm pumps got you always everyone to
get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy pumps gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a Playstation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine comm tell
them tom sent you and thank me later as
many of you know crypto investors store
their digital assets on exchanges or in
cold storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or
ether at block five and receive 6%
annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly high
rate it's the best rate in the industry
I highly suggest you go check out block
Viacom / pop again that's block 5 comm /
pop - sign up and start earning crypto
today Anthony pomp lion-o is a partner
at Morgan Creek Digital all opinions
expressed by pump or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
Digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got Phil
here with us thanks so much for taking
the time to do this and talk about what
you guys are working on Phil thank you
thank you for having me thank you for
this opportunity for sure let's let's
jump right in
talk about your background a little bit
before you started working on crypto and
then Hardware walls yeah well my career
started early 2000s you know I started
an e-book company called the Alex
eReader that company got sold and became
you know their first Barnes and Noble
ebook reader called the Nook and then I
quickly joined HTC 2007 and at HTC Oh as
a product manager I built their first
Android phone we shipped a 2008 yeah I
know was at HTC basically from 2007 or
fourteen the last thing I left before
they shoot HTC 2014 was I started the
vive the VR headset but then I left
today we we launched a dev kit to start
you know a VR AR fund called Presidents
capital a year into that it was a seed
fund a year into that I joined a much
bigger fund in Hong Kong which is li
kai-shing venture fund you know I did
all of the kind of the deep tech a lot
of the AI investments and horizons has a
history of you know investing in many
disruptive companies including you know
companies like Siri that Apple acquired
or D
mind that Google acquired and that's
where I really started learning a lot
about you know crypto and blockchain
public box chains horizons we had
invested in companies like block stream
you know the earlier Bitcoin kind of
blockchain companies and it had also
invested in DCG you know TCG of course
is one of the most prolific investors in
Bitcoin startups and that's how I kind
of got you know started learning you
know about Bitcoin and public block
chains and that's how I really started
to get really really interested in
understanding that you know it was the
most I think the most disruptive
technologies I've been in touch with and
what I find fascinating is in those
years investing I was there from
basically 2015 18 I started investing 14
or 14 14 2018 and I looked at every you
know vertical like from biotech to
FinTech to AI to autonomous driving to
robotics and every single vertical was
dominated by the same players you know
namely Google Amazon Facebook in China
as Baidu volleyball about $0.10 but
there was only one vertical or one
technology that that wasn't owned by
these you know these you know the big
four or some people call like alpha and
that was crypto you know nobody owned
Bitcoin you know a theorem came up and
you know it was crowd-sourced
and so it was the most fascinating
disruptive technology that you know I
wanted to spend you know my time with
yeah and then that's how it got really
really interested into into crypto got
it and talked a little bit about you
know HTC what your role there is and
kind of that will get into what you're
working on yeah so you know originally
you know you know at horizons you know
we are investing in disruptive tech you
know including
a lot of the public of blockchain and
crypto companies and you know because of
my years there from 2007 or 14 I still
had a you know deep relationship with a
lot of the executives and board members
and I simply pitched them the idea right
you know our you know I actually learned
most of my Bitcoin stuff from Andreas
Antonopoulos you know I I literally
watch hundreds of hours of Andreas on
YouTube and listen to his podcast you
know and it all came down to you know if
you don't own your private keys you know
own your Bitcoin right and of course you
know treasure and ledger many other
hardware laws were very popular and in
in in empowering the user to own their
private keys and then I simply went back
to htz I mean not thinking that I would
go back and build this but kind of
seeding the idea to you know some board
members and the CEO of HDC saying hey
you should build a phone and empower the
users to only priorities on the phone
because the phone is the most prevalent
device right I mean today you know you
talk about you know two billion unbanked
you know people or even three billion
under banked or even more right and over
half of those people have mobile phones
right and if you can build a mobile
phone with a hardware wallet that
empowers people to own their private
keys it allows them it banks them
basically you know we can talk about
that later but the idea was ceded to
them you know and then they decide okay
it's very interesting and so you know
they put up a kind of a thunk skunkworks
team to start building prototypes you
know and then come like you know late
2000 or mid 2018 and became really
serious right but then there was there
was nobody that understood how to make a
phone yeah yeah understand the whole
crypto space or even understand what it
means to have or heart or wall-e on a
phone
empowers user you own their private keys
and so that's kinda how I decided okay I
think I need to go back in and build
things again and so and this was
meaningful enough for me to do that
because I feel like you know HTC is a
company well-positioned to do this you
know because it didn't have the cloud
legacy's business you know like every
other business like people ask me you
know what if google comes in and do this
or facebook or you know Apple come and
do this and you know we don't what do
you do you know and you know I thought
through that and the conclusion I came
up to is I don't think Google or
Facebook or Apple will do this because
it's completely countercultural to their
business model because the past not just
past 20 years but past 50 years the way
you make money is to own the customer
and own all of their data and that's how
Google and Facebook make money and what
we're doing is the exact opposite right
we're giving people ownership on their
private keys right and based on that
right now they're only their Bitcoin but
based on that we want to empower them to
own their data the digital identities in
any sensitive or you know important
information and so you know if she C is
a company that did really well from 2007
and 12 you know it didn't do well in the
cloud business it didn't do well and
owning people's data and mining and
monetizing off of that and to me it was
the best you know it was it is and it
still had a good reputation and being
able to build good hardware and so to me
it was like the the the perfect company
to to build this kind of contrary and
countercultural product you know and so
yeah that's what motor me motivated me
to you know leave a very very
comfortable venture capital job you know
to go back to the trenches and then
build this for sure and so before we get
into what you guys specifically but
let's just talk about kind of hardware
wallets in general what you
assessment of the lay of the land you
know with what other people have built
good bad and in between yeah no I you
know I think treasure and ledger have
built a great product you know and I
think for people who hold a lot of
Bitcoin you know that's you know that's
that's one of the main ways to do it
right except you know the the way you
use it is it's very difficult right like
you know you you you for you to start
transacting you would have to you know
again your treasure you would have to
plug you to have to have a laptop right
you plug it you know it's a USB you plug
it into your laptop and then you open a
browser and then you have to open up
meta mask you know or some wallet and
then you transact right that's you know
four or five or at least two Hardware
pieces and you know three or four
software kind of combinations right and
what we've done is we've done that all
on the phone basically right
we built that uh you know that whole
browser meta mask laptop to USB stick
that whole chain into you know what you
would be used to using in a you know in
an app and a smartphone right so just
making a much more user-friendly and
easier right and yeah I think uh you
know what ledger and treasure have done
is it's great you know but I think to
get it to more mass adoption it needs to
be people are so used to using their
mobile phones having it on a mobile
phone is you know is much more
accessible and I also just think it's
completely different use cases right
it's like you know you could call it
maybe your savings account versus your
checking account right maybe you would
have your savings on you know a you know
a ledger or treasure where you keep at
home where people don't don't see it but
at some point when you know a big point
where we start building out Bitcoin not
just as a store value
but you know when we build out the
Lightning stuff when it becomes a
payment system you know you need to
carry something to make payments right
you retailers need a point-of-sale
system to receive payments right and so
we're just laying down that foundation
for people to be able to have access to
that infrastructure on mobile right and
I think that's that's gonna be one of my
key topics that I talk about in a
lightning conference is what is Bitcoin
on mobile right these two most powerful
forces mobile that shaped everything
that we know about usability and access
but then Bitcoin this other revolution
and I'm just basically combining these
two revolutions I actually find it
fascinating that you know when I
launched the first Android phone you
know I thought I was you know I love you
know I joined it because I believe in
open source right Android was that open
source software and we launched her
first Android phone and of course you
know the reason why I got into this
space was because I believed in that
that promise of the Internet right open
sharing or knowledge
open access the information right but
what happened was you know this whole
Android Google open source movement
became a way to hijack people's data
right and what I find fascinating was
that I launched or we launched at HTC
the first Android phone October of 2008
and 2009 January was the first Bitcoin
was a Genesis block right to me that was
the that was the real revolution or the
real kind of successor of you know open
source kind of movement and so like 10
years later 2018 and launched accidents
and I just found that fascinating that
launching their first Android phone and
the first Bitcoin was was so close
together except we weren't paying
attention you know and now I'm paying
attention and
and the potential of a Bitcoin on mobile
it's just so fascinating for sure
so let's talk a little bit about exactly
what you guys have built because you are
now on is just the kind of updated
version the second version or that
conversion okay
and so second my understanding is that
you guys have built a phone
it makes phone calls texts got internet
access kind of everything that a normal
phone does that HTC would you know build
and release but also you have added the
hardware wallet and a full Bitcoin node
to it as well correct yes yes
so yeah I'll do maybe I maybe highlight
four or five things right yes first it's
a smart phone right and second it's a
it's a hardware wallet it's basically
this this secluded area on the chip
that's that Android doesn't touch right
it's basically a physical space where we
keep your private keys right so it's
first that is a smartphone Plus or
Hardware wallet and then we have you
know other really interesting features
like secure UI you know what that is is
you know once when you want to sign
transactions right and your private keys
are so important to protect right you
can imagine that people want a hack and
I get you and steal your private keys
right and so we want to make sure that
private keys is never revealed right and
so we have something called secure UI
which is basically the touch screen
basically itself has a hard line into
the secure area and so you can't you you
can't steal people's passwords or you
know do you know kind of phishing ways
of stealing people's data by you know
faking a home screen that people punch
in their password kind of thing you know
and so once it once it you use our our
Hardware wallet basically there's a UI
that goes only to the secure zone
that's not a that Android can
axis you know so the secure UI just adds
another layer of security that's what
makes it more secure than a software
wallet write a software wallet is still
on Android and you know Android is
successful susceptible to many hacks
right what we've done is put it in this
truss on the arm trestle that's separate
from Android and just significantly
reduce the the attack surface area right
and so it keeps your private keys safe
right and then it keeps your transaction
safe with a secure UI and then often the
next question I guess and this is
another significant piece of technology
that we built is what happens when you
lose your phone right you know and so we
build something called a social key
recovery and what that is is when you
set up your hardware wallets will split
your keys into five different parts and
you share those five parts to five of
your friends or family all they have to
do is download an app and they keep one
in the five and so when you lose your
phone you can recover your keys by
combining three out of the five keys
from you know from your friends and
family and so just to show that you know
you know HTC when we ship you the phone
we don't have access to your private
keys so when you lose your phone you
can't call HTC right in fact there's a
there's a funny story in which there is
a Bitcoin magazine kind of generalist I
was asking me this trick question like
what happens when you lose your phone
you know because they had to ask that
same question to a Chinese manufacturer
and the Chinese manufacturer said oh
it's easy we'll recover your keys from
our cloud right
and yeah they so immediately didn't you
that you know this is you know this big
this blockchain phone conversation is
not real because you're not serious
about giving people tools to own their
private
keys right and so and so the social key
recovery is it's something we've built
and we open sourced it and others to
other wallets or anybody else can use
this key recovery mechanism and so so
we're just also in the spirit of open
source and and and you know sharing the
code that we've built you know and so
yeah and then this latest one the Exodus
1s so that we're launching you know end
of this week at the Lightning
conferences well first it's a much more
accessible price the first Exodus one
was around $700 this new one will be
around two hundred US dollars or with
tax will be about 220 euros and and much
more accessible and you know it's still
a smartphone it's a functioning
smartphone with a functioning hardware
wallet right with social key recovery
and secure UI all of that and now we're
adding the other new functionality for
you to run a full Bitcoin node right and
so you can verify transactions yourself
you can relay transactions right of
course we suggest that you have your
phone plugged in with Wi-Fi access you
know there are some bandwidth and
battery requirements but you can run a
full Bitcoin own you know when your
phone is plugged in at night right
and so you can help secure the network
you know you can help contribute to the
community and I think that's that's what
we want to build tools to empower people
but build software tools for people to
join this community and be a part of
this whole Bitcoin network skirts car
want to know who has the best URL crypto
calm that's right crypto calm they're
crypto platform with one goal mother
mass adoption that's why we're all here
we're trying to get crypto in every
wallet crypto calm is helping people do
that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine calm
tell them pomp Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor block buy
their new interest account allows you to
securely deposit your Bitcoin or ether
at block five and receive six percent
annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compounds so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm slash pop again block 5 comm slash
pump to sign up and start earning
interest on your crypto today as part of
this like what do you see the response
from the market being right because you
know look it's pretty cool to one have a
full hardware wallet on my on my phone
be able to store Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency securely have the social
recovery aspect to it so I lose my phone
I don't feel like you know I'm gonna
lose all my well then you add in the
Bitcoin node which allows me to
participate and help secure the network
and really you know kind of fulfill part
of what the Bitcoin ethos and can goal
is and then you add into that a very low
price
point that that is competitive for any
phone let alone one that has the this
functionality do you see others kind of
scrambling to respond or do you think
this is something where you guys are
gonna have a significant advantage
moving forward for quite a long time I
mean I do see others getting in although
because it's such a contrary point of
view like why would you give people
access to the private keys and let them
own their crypto I mean it's it's
already kind of countercultural even in
crypto right because 95% of the people
still have their keys and centralized
exchanges right so even in the crypto
world it's it's it's it's counter it's
contrary it's it's it's not mainstream
behavior right because still most of the
speculators still have their keys and
centralized exchanges in the cloud
rather than in some you know a leisure
or treasure or a hardware wallet or even
a cold storage you know let alone you
know the phone right and so you know if
you move to the mainstream then it's
even more contrary and like people don't
even get it right and so you know III
don't know if you would I would say that
were the only ones you know we have a
big advantage but it's such a contrary
and we're thinking that I think you know
I don't see it as an advantage I see it
more like hey you know very few people
like right now many it's still the early
adopters and the developers that are
buying this phone and developing this
phone and kind of seeing the potential
of it rather than you know kind of the
mass-market you know who want to use
this you know will actually want to
trade even for speculation purposes and
so it's it's something like I meet so
many people in the Bitcoin space and
like I never got this kind of response
you know even building the Android phone
you know big people in the Bitcoin space
like I go to South America I go to you
know Silicon Valley and I
get sincere thank-yous they just say
thank you for doing what you do because
they know nobody's gonna do that you
know let alone an institution a
respectable institution have the right
mind to do this right because it's it's
borderless it's open it's you know it's
neutral it's you know it's public you
know it's all of those things that's so
again counterculture I'm sorry to use
them so many times but that's what it is
and like that's what really it motivates
me it's like people in the community is
far and few but they come to me and say
thank you for what you do you know
because they know if so few people will
stand for that
and as long as as long I can build this
and you know I'm gonna keep standing on
that principle of the power use it are
used on their private keys and it's it's
it's and it's not easy right it's not
easy to stand for that because people
don't get it you know and you know very
very few people even today even in the
crypto space or behaviorally our art
aren't doing that too and so yeah I
don't know if I see that as an advantage
but it's the flea I don't see anybody in
the near term really doing that either
you know or even the way we contribute
to the open-source community right I
mean we don't just take everything we
like the whole social key recovery we
contributed back to the community
right that's also um you know contrary
and behavior got it
and so what do you think is kind of the
challenges ahead for you guys
specifically heard there are other
things that you want to build into the
phone moving forward and if so what
would those be and kind of what what
could potentially be an obstacle as you
move to do that I think you know uh you
know I think most people see Bitcoin as
a store of value right they see that as
a killer app and you know I see
definitely that's one of the main killer
apps but Bitcoin also encrypt on the
to move into the medium of exchange to
into payments right I think that's where
mobile is really going to shine because
if payments don't take off right and if
it's just a store of value then it's
probably smart that you don't keep all
your crypto on a mobile phone right
because it's something you carry with
you all the time
right again it's more like this that's
this distinction between a savings and a
checking account right you want to keep
your savings account even if you you're
you you are your own bank or you hold
custody or you own your private keys you
want that savings to be at home and you
know not on the go with you all the time
right but as a payment system you want
it with you all the time because you
want to use it to pay for coffee for
transportation for for anything on it on
a daily basis right and so that's been
the challenge right and that's why I'm
really focused on you know building up
helping in contributing to the Lightning
Network because that will help make it a
true you know medium of exchange too
right people they people you know a
mechanism where people can use as a
payment realm right and that would be
the most killer application for Bitcoin
on mobile and even for retail and
merchants to use as a point-of-sale
system right you can just use a mobile
phone to be your your point-of-sale
system right and so I would say yeah
it's that it's you know how do we get
you know Bitcoin to be a medium of
exchange or day to day payment mechanism
you know that's what I really want to
you know help build and contributed next
for sure
no and and I guess the big thing here
for you really is this is less about can
you guys build the different
functionality it's probably more
prioritization than anything right
because there's so many different things
that you could do we're still so
surely that if you can prioritize things
correctly naturally you know at least to
me would feel like we're a lot of the
the opportunity lies as well yes and
there's so many things I mean on a super
high level like the things we're
challenging our money right that's what
bitcoin is challenging and then number
two is data right if you look at the top
ten companies today like you know Amazon
Google Facebook and JPMorgan like I
would say seven out of the ten are
either money companies banks or data
companies like Google and Facebook right
and right now we're really focused on
the money part right you know I mean
once you empower somebody to own their
private keys basically what you've done
is you've give them the tools to be
their own bank you know or universal
access to basic finance right once you
have your private keys you set up a
hardware wallet you know you can send
and receive money right you can buy and
trade and sell right and then now you
know with stable coins coming in you can
even lend and borrow now and voila you
know these are the the three main things
of bank stuff right but what does a bank
do are paying stores your money it
allows you to make payments number two
and number three it lends and let you
borrow those are the three main things I
paint does right and now with the phone
or the private key or the hard wallet
you can do all those three right and so
that's what you want to do we want to
make we want to build out you know those
three main behaviors and so what we've
done with I think with an exodus 1s or
what at this price point is to give
someone universal access to basic
finance and basic banking tools right
and what's even cooler is we have an SDK
so we're not just empowering you to be a
bank but we're a bank
an SDK to empower you and the developer
developer to make up even better bake
right how do you build a better local
exchange or better exchange way from
Fiat to crypto or cryptography on
on-ramps you know or how do you build a
better remittance have you know there's
so many things and in the money space
that you can build but what we're doing
is empowering you to be your own bank
but we took it one step further because
you can use our hardware to sign
transactions we're a bank with an SDK
and I think that completely changes the
game right I love it man I love it
where can people find on the phone HTC
Exodus com yeah WWE HTC Exodus comm you
know we have an e-commerce site
we'll start opening right now you can
already buy the Exodus one you know we
take we even take Bitcoin and Eve as
payment and the exodus 1s will be start
selling this Saturday that's awesome and
as you do this I always answer or finish
up with rapid-fire set of questions what
uh what do you think it's the most
important company in crypto other than
HTC I think bina's might be one of them
I think you know lightning labs might be
one of them these are kind of people who
are really pushing the agenda and trying
new things you know a lot of times
ignoring regulation or I have a strategy
for arbitrage gene regulation risk but
yeah I think you know these companies
are doing or experimenting with the
right things what's the one regulation
you would change or improve if you could
kyc AML privacy yeah like why why
regulate that you know I mean look it's
legitimate
questioner right as to why to do it it
is and and what you do it then you
become surveillance and what's you know
what's what are we giving up when we end
that and what what is what's happened is
the result is right now two billion
unbanked people because they're not
worthy to be baked right it's too
expensive to bake them it takes too many
lawyers it takes too many accountants it
takes too many bureaucrats and it takes
too many police officers to enforce and
so you you leave two billion people
unbanked and three billion under of
eight that is the reality and that's
that's not gonna change the current
banking system is simply not scalable
right when Nick Szabo wrote that
incredible post on social scalability I
think that's what he's referring to
right what you're giving access you know
sure Bitcoin and proof of work you know
computation takes a lot of power right
and a lot of energy but what have you
replaced we replaced lawyers accountants
bureaucrats bank tellers and the police
force that's a lot of stuff you're
you're you're replacing four four four
the proof of work that you're you're
you're getting you know and the security
and the distributed ledger and the
empowering of anybody to be there become
their own bank yeah it's just it's to me
it is it's a it's a great trade off yeah
I mean look it's a it's a no-brainer at
this point right I think my I joke all
the time and say we've left the if part
of this equation and just gotten into
the wind so it'll happen it's just take
some time what I wasn't book you've ever
read I think one of the more recent was
these past few years has been you know
antifragile which is the Sinta leaves
book have you read that book I have yeah
and it's just though the whole concept
and he you know he talks about Bitcoin
is very anti fragile it was just a
completely
a way of thinking about markets and
products and you know having skin in the
game and that that book skin in the game
motivate motivated me to come back and
build this too because you know I was in
a very comfortable venture capital job
of investing in Bitcoin but until you go
and build it yourself you don't have
skin in the game right so I decided to
put some skin in the game and come back
to build this thing that nobody's gonna
build in the short term for sure I love
it name aliens real not real
leave our non-believer uh I think
there's something out there probably
that's it
yeah well I'm a physicist by training
too and so you know I follow the Drake
Equation and you know the probability
seems pretty that that you know it's
it's you know there there should be some
intelligence there's definitely
intelligence outside of outside of us I
don't know if they're aliens but some
intelligence I love it I love it
ok and then what one question do you
have for me to finish up what do you
thinks the most you know important kind
of breakthrough for Bitcoin or the most
important company in this space what
what do you think needs to happen or
what needs that sorry questions what
needs to happen technology and which
company that's the most important thing
I actually don't think it's a technology
I think it's just time right it it takes
time for people to be comfortable with
new ideas it takes time for people to be
familiar with new ideas it takes time
for the technology to get built it takes
time for people to adopt it right all
these things are just a function of time
and so you know patience is probably
undervalued in this market but but but
taking time obviously is important here
then when it comes to the companies you
know the one answer I have to this that
we always forget about it's like there's
people who are building Bitcoin right
like not building applications for
Bitcoin especially for the actual
developers who are
looking on Bitcoin sure I you know look
there are there companies helping with
that yes of course but I just put all of
the developers who are contributing code
etc in a bucket and say like they are
usually forgotten and they are much much
more important than most people would
like to admit or understand
and so to me they are the ones that are
kind of the unsung heroes here and you
know while they're not a true
corporation I think they're probably the
most important can't disagree with that
right difficult yeah you made an
airtight argue bit too hard to disagree
with hey here's the way I look at it is
they did something I couldn't do so all
right my book yeah all right man listen
super pumped that you took the time to
do this you know obviously what you guys
are building is it's pretty commendable
so anyone who wants to go out and check
out the the HTC Exodus can do that it's
got a full digital wallet got a full
Bitcoin note in there and and hopefully
you guys will keep shipping awesome
products and we'll have you back on
again to it to talk about great let's
pump I appreciate you giving me this
this this opportunity hey everyone pop
here if you like this episode of off the
chain and want to help us take crypto to
the top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain homepage
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars taking 15 seconds to fill those
stars in and leave a quick review goes a
long way in helping us take the entire
crypto ecosystem to the top of the
charts I appreciate you listening and
see you next time on off the chain
you